después de rumanía de manuel ma con
yegua moldavia este país es uno de los
más pobres de europa está en primera
línea al conflicto ucraniano ha recibido
a más de 400.000 refugiados de los
cuales 10.000 siguen en su territorio
quiero expresar la admiración de francia
por la oleada de solidaridad de la
población moldava en la acogida de los
refugiados ucranianos
con 15 millones de ayuda presupuestaria
37 toneladas de material y ambulancias
entregadas en pocos días francia es uno
de los principales países en la ayuda a
moldavia
este apoyo continuará mi solución al mtc
y ctp son en sí mismos un tóxico durante
su visita a rumanía el mandatario
francés visitó una base de la otan en la
que se encuentran 500 soldados franceses
desplegados de urgencia desde principios
de marzo macrón quiso dejar las cosas
claras y dijo que no tiene ninguna
complacencia como escudo sin embargo
señaló que las negociaciones siguen
siendo la única forma de poner fin a la
guerra
y dio máxima magíster con luz suites en
algún momento cuando esperó ucrania haya
ganado cuando el fuego haya cesado el
presidente ucraniano tendrá que negociar
con rusia seguir y yo
el presidente francés reiteró el apoyo
inquebrantable de la unión europea los
ucranianos pero no está claro si
continuará su viaje a kiev mientras
francia ejerce la presidencia del
consejo de la unión europea manuel macon
sigue siendo uno de los pocos líderes
europeos que aún no ha pisado suelo
ucraniano